>> Laura: TODAY HOUSE DEMOCRATS
VOTED TO CRIMINALIZE THEIR
POLITICAL OPPOSITION UNDER THE
GUISE OF PREVENTING DOMESTIC
TERRORISTS.
IT WILL SET UP OFFICES TO
VISITING DOMESTIC TERRORISTS AT
THE DS AND THE DOJ.
WHAT IS THE GOAL?
MORE SURVEILLANCE AND TRACKING
AMERICANS.
THIS IS ALL POLITICAL.
OUR NEXT GUEST ISSUED A WARNING
ON TWITTER TODAY:
THEY VOTED TO GIVE THE FBI AND
DOJ MORE POWER TO FIGHT DOMESTIC
TERRORISM.
THE SQUAD COMES THROUGH AGAIN
FOR THE U.S. SECURITY STATE.
GLEN GREENWALD, WELCOME.
ONE OF THE BILL'S SUPPORTERS
SNYDER CLAIMS THAT THE
LEGISLATION WAS ADJUSTED TO SAY
NONE OF ITS AMENDMENTS UNDERMINE
FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS.
WHAT IS THE PROBLEM?
>> PRETTY MUCH EVERY BILL THAT
HAS BEEN ENAC  ACTED SINCE THE
9-11 ACT CONTAINS SIMILAR
PROMISES.
MANY RAN ROUGHSHOD OVER THE
CIVIL RIGHTS OF AMERICAN
CITIZENS -- MOST PEOPLE AGREE.
THIS IS MORE DANGEROUS BECAUSE
UNLIKE THE FIRST WAR ON TERROR
WHICH WAS DIRECTED OUT WARD.
THIS IS INCREASINGLY A WAR ON
TERROR ON DOMESTIC SOIL, ON
AMERICAN CITIZENS.
I HAVE BEEN ON YOUR SHOW MANY
TIMES GOING BACK TO BEFORE
BIDEN'S INAUGURATION WARNING
THIS THE DEMOCRAT'S PLAN.
BEFORE JANUARY 6TH BIDEN SAID
A NEW WAR ON TERROR IS MY NUMBER
1 PRIORITY.
THEY ARE EXPLOITING JANUARY 6TH
AND NOW EXPLOITING THE BUFFALO
SHOOTINGS TO GIVE AGENCIES MORE
POWER TO CONTROL OUR FREE
SPEECH.
>> Laura: THERE ARE NO STANDARDS
HERE.
THESE ASSURANCES THAT FREE
EXPRESSION, THEY WON'T BE
TOUCHED HERE.
THERE ARE NO CHECKS AND
BALANCES.
WHATEVER THEY CONSIDER TO BE
HATE SPEECH, MAYBE YOU POST
SOMETHING AGAINST LOCKDOWNS.
THAT'S HATE SPEECH.
MAYBE YOU CRITICIZE A NEW
SPENDING BILL.
THAT'S HATE SPEECH.
THERE IS NO END IN SIGHT AS TO
WHAT CONSTITUTES HATE SPEECH AND
COULD LEAD TO DOMESTIC TERROR
DOWN THE ROAD.
>> THIS IS A PROBLEM WITH THE
CONTROVERSY THAT JUST ERUPTED
WHERE THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY ANNOUNCED THEY WERE
CREATING A BOARD TO COMBAT
DISINFORMATION.
IN THEORY NOBODY IS AGAINST
THERE THEY PROMISED AND SAID
THIS BOARD IS GOING TO PROTECT
YOUR CIVIL RIGHTS SO YOU DON'T
NEED TO WORRIED.
THE DEMOCRATS THINK EVERY VIEW
THAT SUBVERTS THEIR AGENDA IS
DISINFORMATION.
PRIOR TO THE ELECTION THEY
CALLED THE HUNTER BIDEN LAPTOP
RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION AND GOT
IT CENSORED FROM THE INTERNET.
WHEN YOU PUT THESE ELASTIC
PHRASES AS THE CENTERPIECE FOR
THE GOVERNMENT'S POWER.
THAT'S WHAT  WHEN CIVIL RIGHTS
VIOLATIONS OCCUR.
THEY ARE TRYING TO CONTROL
DOMESTIC CRIMINAL ACTIVITY -->>
Laura: ON THE ISSUE OF UKRAINE.
YOU HAVE BEEN MONITORING THE
BILLS.
MITCH MCCONNELL WAS ON FOX
DISCUSSING THIS.
>> WHAT IT WILL COST REMAINS TO
BE SEEN.
THE IMPORTANT THING TO REMEMBER
WHAT WOULD HAVE BEEN THE COST OF
NOT ACTING.
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN WAY MORE.
WAY MORE THAN 40 BILLION
DOLLARS.
>> Laura: I AM NOT SURE ABOUT
THAT.
40 BILLION DOLLARS AND KAMALA
HARRIS IS NOT RULING OUT WE ARE
SPENDING MORE.
IT COULD BE HUNDREDS OF BILLION
DOLLARS.
>> IT IS GOING THERE.
THAT 40 BILLION DOLLARS FIGURE
THAT MITCH MCCONNELL CITE SIDE
FALSE.
THEY VOTED TO IT ADD 40 BILLION
DOLLARS MORE.
JUST 10 WEEKS INTO A WAR THEY
SAY WILL LAST NOT MONTHS BUT
YEARS.
WE GOT DONE SPENDING 2 TRILLION
DOLLARS FOR A 20 YEAR WAR IN
AFGHANISTAN THAT ACHIEVED
NOTHING BUT THE DEATH OF OUR
SOLDIERS ONLY FOR THE TALIBAN TO
WALTZ BACK IN.
WHAT YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT IS
NOT SPENDING BILLION DOLLARS TO
HELP THE UKRAINE PEOPLE.
THIS MONEY IS GOING TO LOCKHEED
MARTIN AND THE CIA TO DO WHAT?
NOBODY KNOWS.
RAND PAUL WANTED TO SLOW DOWN
THE BILL FOR OVERSIGHT.
YOU HAVE HUGE AMOUNTS OF MONEY
FLYING OUT THE DOOR.
NOBODY CAN ARTICULATE A STRATEGY
FOR WHEN WE ARE DOING AND
BENEFITS FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
>> Laura: LOST 80 BILLION
DOLLARS WORTH OF EQUIPMENT IN
AFGHANISTAN.
TONIGHT MITCH McCONNELL WENT
AFTER RAND PAUL.
THEY WILL NEVER DEBATE.
I WANT TO SEE RAND PAUL AND
McCONNELL DEBATE.
THEY ARE BOTH REALLY SMART.
DEBATE THE NUMBERS AND THE
ISSUES TO TOWN HALLS ACROSS
KENTUCKY AND SEE WHICH PERSON
COMES OUT ON TOP.
WHO DO YOU THINK WOULD COME OUT
ON TOP WITH THE PUBLIC?
>> RAND PAUL HAS THE MUCH BETTER
ARGUMENT.
NO MATTER WHAT YOU THINK ABOUT
UKRAINE AND WE ALL FEEL SYMPATHY
FOR THE UKRAINIANS.
THIS IS THE MOST DANGEROUS WAR
THE UNITED STATES HAS FOUGHT IF
DECADES.
OUR OPPONENT IS NOT IRAQ OR
AFGHANISTAN BUT A COUNTRY WITH
THE LARGEST NUCLEAR STOCKPILE ON
THE PLANET.
WE ARE RISKING NUCLEAR
ANNIHI